if i have that toy i'll be unstoppable
it's foolproof you are proof that there
are fools
fools boots fools fools fools food
keegan
very good job in the film it's so it's
so colorful and fun and it just like i
think adds to the already like great
history
of like musical christmas movies like
white christmas
st louis i mean even elf so i'm just
curious
why do you think christmas and musicals
is like such a great pairing
i think it's because we we automatically
associate christmas with some kind of
magical element so you go you go well
it's already magic
so why wouldn't people just burst into
song you know what i mean
i mean it's like it's they're they're
meant to be together it's like there's
fruit in there
why don't we put crust on top who
doesn't want fruit
and bread you know yeah right
so i i think that's the thing it's that
magical aspect lends itself to
us suspending our disbelief almost
immediately when the songs come in
yeah yeah that was the same thing
because i mean this movie it like kicks
off and it does not hide it's like we
are a musical and we are living in it we
are not
unabashed at all and so i'm curious
though for you because i know
like you have a long theater just not on
broadway but also improv
um is there a favorite like movie that
you like that's just christmas or is it
like a favorite one of those christmas
musicals either one
it's so there's two movies that that are
that are my kind of christmas movies one
is a christmas story with peter
billingsly
i love that it's just a film just a
piece a small little piece of christmas
cinema and
and it's because it it it's it's also a
period piece but because of the way it
was shot
it just feels like it lives in its own
world even though it's set in the 50s
it's
it doesn't look it looks old but it
looks the way it's supposed to look
it it doesn't feel like it was made in
the 80s you know what i mean there's
something very
special about that film and the other
one i think i'm getting this right
1973 74
there's a movie called scrooge which is
a christmas carol and it stars albert
finney
and he plays scrooge and it's where if
you've ever heard the song
thank you very much thank you very much
that's the kindest thing that anyone's
ever done for me
that's from that musical have you ever
heard that song no
i've heard of that song but i did not
know about albert finney in a musical
and i feel like
oh my gosh i really want to watch this
now yeah look up his filmography
and i think it's just called scrooge you
know exclamation point
and it's one of these big casts of
hundreds uh
uh dank kind of like gritty 70s but
it's it's the um it's it's the christmas
carol story and
albert finney plays scrooge yeah yeah i
love that all right i'm gonna look that
up
right away um bringing it back to jingle
jangle your character and your
performance in particular
you had to do everything that you would
have to do on like a broadway musical
and then you had to add in like you're
talking to cgi characters and they're
like
practical so talk about how you actually
filmed this because it seems like this
is a
this is a very complicated dance y'all
are doing yeah we had a real
interesting uh technology that was
available to us where we had a guy who
was
in mocap in a room next to the room
where we were
at video village so when i came off
stage for reference i could come over
and look at a monitor
jacqueline that literally had him the
guy in the
room is moving around and on the monitor
i'm watching don juan
walk around so they got yeah so then i'd
go around the corner
and i would and they would they'd have a
little figurine of don juan or
or sometimes a ball like a tennis ball
and like go so right here keegan then
he's gonna move and then i would go like
this and look around yeah
okay so i'm to the okay and i'd watch
him the actor
and so we were it was really it was
amazing and then
later ricky ricky martin did his mo-cap
in los angeles so it was the the the cgi
elements were fantastic and then
when buddy doesn't work when i get buddy
and he doesn't have and i don't believe
and he doesn't work
um i had a practical buddy so that was
practical
and then in the dance number the whirly
twirly is not there
so we're dancing we're singing and we're
looking at nothing
and we're and we're all looking there's
just a man standing with a stick
and we're all following the stick around
and and the academy award goes to keegan
michael key
for dancing and giving me all kinds of
face
with a a like you know nothing there so
i appreciate you
sir it's even more incredible hearing
you say that and shame on them for not
letting you have ricky martin but
that's for another day
[Laughter]
bye sir nice take care bye-bye
jacqueline
jangle for the last 30 years
you've been promising something
sensational i need more time
either come up with the money you've
borrowed by christmas or show me the
revolutionary invention you once
promised
how you doing hi how are y'all um first
of all gentlemen
much congratulations on the film it is
just like a transportation
into like a beautiful like black
christmas special that i was like so
happy to see
um let's start with you david um because
i know this was like a labor of love but
why do you think music and christmas why
do those like pair together so well and
want to keep like revisiting this
this version of story i i think uh
everyone has their favorite songs that
you could you know you can sing
without even thinking about it from the
holiday or there's a song that just
makes you
mine was a magalia jackson christmas you
know
do you hear what i hear i remember her
singing
every single christmas my mother would
put on the mahalia jackson christmas
uh record so it's it's just kind of part
of your dna
the holidays but not only the love of it
but the loss
from it is in our dna so it makes you
give you pause
as much joy as it gives you it also
gives you pause to remember
you know those so i i just think it's i
i think you can't have one without the
other and then to put all these classic
new songs in there this just
makes it takes it over the top yeah and
forrest he put you to work on this one
you had to do like a little sing a
little dance and it was like a lot
and then you had to fly i know i was to
say and then all of the like cg
impractical so talk about the actual
filming because when i was talking to
keegan he said it's a big marriage
between like
literally a whole bunch of different
elements well keegan had to deal
with like the doll and stuff and
um no you know what was cool what was
great about it was that even though
there were some cg elements but
they built the center square of the town
and my shop was built
it was two stories high and then you
know so i could go in and touch the toys
and see them moving around
i got a chance to go in the back into my
little workshop area and like
settle there even before weeks before we
started to shoot maybe a month before i
don't remember
um and it really like fuels your own
imagination as an actor too to be able
to do that and
it just kept growing the dancers came
the artist came the music started to
play people started to sing
it was a it was an amazing experience
actually i mean it really shows it does
look like everybody's having a good time
even though i'm looking at it like that
was like
six weeks of rehearsal and then some to
get ready for that so
i'm just curious like you've done
theater before and
everybody i think in here has done some
form of theater is it more difficult
like maybe eight shows a week or is it
like this is the last take we have to
get it like which one is the more
stressful element
of the theater live or like we've got to
get this perfect with like all of the
moving parts i mean it is something
about
something that's live that uh especially
when when you're like moving through it
and you feel like you make a mistake and
stuff you can guide yourself through it
but it's a little different
on film you shoot it and then they shoot
it again or
even if it's the last thing you've shot
some things before and it's a little
different
you know but but there's a give off
you know because in the theater you get
to feel the audience's presence much
so strongly and in the film part you're
like living
and even though it's bigger insular kind
of invent and
there's something special about both you
know
yeah and i think this film really like
it does feel like very theater in a way
but then it also has its own little i
think sort of vibe to it
and david i wanted to talk to you about
this one because the production design
and just like the look of the film is
really just so incredible
and i'm just curious are there any
particular elements that you were
inspired by that you wanted to make sure
you added into this because it does feel
very unique but it it just still screams
christmas
well you know it's just like uh the
going into jangles and things for the
first time i mean if you close your eyes
and you think well what is the
what is the best version of a
a toy store uh my childhood well that's
it and i wanted to create it and what i
found was it wasn't just me that had
that
i had there were at least 500 people
working on the set there were 500
grown adults that became kids
every time they walked to that stage and
they put the best version of their
childhood
into the film so it wasn't just me
reliving my childhood or getting in
touch with my inner child it was
everybody and that was the spirit of the
set
it was it was and it's a spirit of the
film and i think that's
why it's something for multi-generations
you know
for the kid for the adult with the kid
in them for the grandmother
it plays for everybody and i think it's
what the world needs at this time
yeah it definitely hits on that but it
also if even if you're an adult you
think back to like that perfect toy that
you were dreaming about because so much
of the movie is about creating that
toy when a kid gets it that they light
up so i'm just curious if either of you
remember
your favorite christmas present
something from under the tree and i'll
start with you forest and then go to you
david
i got this red bike you know the first
bike i ever got
and i remember really well because that
day we got it and my dad and i went
outside
for me to try to learn how to ride a
bike and he was pushing behind me and i
was going forward and i was nervous and
i remember the moment where i turned
back and he wasn't there you know
and so that was a special special moment
when i was riding the bike for a few
more feet
and then you crashed down of course yeah
i know and then real quick david if you
mind what was your problem
and and you know they'd be knocking each
other's head off my brother and i would
play
and then he hit me my robot really hard
and knocked
his head off but he really knocked it
off you just pulled the knock the head
back and he snapped it and played me
knocked it off
and i'm like mama
[Applause]
robot that's a that's a sad christmas
memory but a memorable one
thank you gentlemen so very much and
again congratulations on the film
thanks sir blessings thank you bye
what's wrong grandpa had a perfect life
loving family and a magical shop
till an old friend took it all
i just wanted to start though by talking
about uh christmas and musicals because
it seems to be this great sort of like
peanut butter and chocolate combination
so i'll start with you anika if you can
tell me why you think christmas and
musicals go so well together
well christmas music
and our film is not filled with
traditional christmas music
you know the score is very christmassy
and it says christmas
but the soundtrack is not traditionally
christmassy
but christmas music i think is some of
the most
beautiful music you can find
which is one reason why i love standards
so much standards remind me of christmas
music anytime i hear standards i'm like
that's like christmas
um it's so melodious it's it's like a
hug
even when it's raucous um and it reminds
me of i don't it just reminds me of
goodness it just reminds it makes me
feel comforted
and and that's how you're supposed to
feel you're supposed to feel joyous
and comforted and happy
and there's something about the bells i
love it
i love it so a christmas musical is
perfect and i love that you said it's
chocolate and peanut butter because it
really is this year
i mean
because i love that you know when people
get ready for a holiday they put on
movies and like this is gonna be the new
black
preamble to christmas like i could
totally see
my mom putting this on the day after
thanksgiving when she starts decorating
your tree is like
the new turn the page so i'm just
curious madeline i mean i
i don't know in your in your tender
years if you've had a lot of christmas
movies that have like
stuck out to you but do you have a
favorite
um my favorite christmas movie
is the live action grinch starring mr
jim carrey
yeah that has to be my favorite because
it's so funny i love it
so much and a great musical too let's
keep it
like jim definitely did it up for that
one
um felicia i'm going to bring it to you
because you did not have to maybe do
all of the huge numbers like everybody
did on every single things like there's
a lot a ton of numbers but there's also
a big marriage between like
practical and what's imagined so i'm
just curious when you were filming your
sections how did
how did you guys make that marriage
together
we just played the scene and we played
the scene for what it
meant what it meant to us as characters
within the scene
um the cinematographer and the director
created the space
the look and the feeling
that that was their work and it was as
if we had stepped into it
and we could play the scene i love it
because you do feel like when you start
this movie like you really do get
transported it is like
right off the get and it's colorful it
lives in its authenticity
and it really is like this is an
unabashed musical where like toys come
alive which i think is really great
and i they sent us like a fun box of
like jingle jangle knickknacks and like
this is going to be like so toy central
but it made me start thinking back to my
favorite
toy when i was a kid like my best
christmas present that i ever got under
the tree and so i'm wondering and i'll
start with you
madeline since you probably remember
better uh what was your favorite
christmas under the tree present where
you were like santa did good
um well
under the tree i haven't had like a
proper
i guess you could say uh christmas tree
or like
celebration because i've actually been
performing for the past three
christmases
but one my favorite gift and my best
gift was
my phone
i i'm not going to think about whatever
and you can really quickly they're
wrapping me but i'm curious if you've
got a best you know
under the under the present tree well it
wasn't under the under the tree
but um it's sort of a tie but i'm going
to choose the year that i got my piano
and i came down and it had a huge ribbon
a big red ribbon on it
and it was beautiful and it was
unexpected and
it was pretty great as a piano player i
feel you on that one sis my piano
right behind this camera thank you
ladies so much for chatting with me and
congratulations again on the film
thank you
today